c'est d'abord un regard celui d'une
femme déterminée
puis une démarche un mouvement avec 3.0
il fera dia s'interroge sur la place de
la femme dans la société à travers
celles qui l'ont inspiré la femme
pourquoi parce que ben en fait c'est un
hommage à un hommage aux femmes qui
m'ont accompagné qui me nourrit voilà
qui ont cru voilà un mois pour citer bon
lamer qui voilà qui avait poussé à
stimuler il ya également mes mentors
donc je lis bien mes mentors parce que
donc initialement j'ai fait mon parcours
de en tant que danseur au sein de la
compagnie de la banda et christine
coudun qui m'a donné toutes les clés
tous les outils qui m'a construit en
tant que danseur mais au courant que
cela en tant qu'individu 3.0 est le
dernier épisode d'un triptyque sur
l'identité de l'être humain
mis en scène par benjamin villemagne des
gestes simples et saccadé ifrad ias a
choisi un style épuré pas ce qui
m'importe
l'associé le croire puisque c'est il
s'agit de normaliser cette féminité et
donc ça passe par une réappropriation du
corps et donc c'est cette volonté que
que de gomme illusion ligne et donc
voilà d'avoir une intense sensuelle
féminines 1
qu'ils soient ni dans l'imitation dit
dans la frustration mais dans
l'expression de la femme complexe
infinie mythique du loch du breakdance
de la new style y fera via mail
différents courants hip hop et montre
que la femme dans la danse a toute sa
place